За Маріуполь і Бучу, за Дніпро і Станіславські Кручі.
Міністерство внутрішніх справ України формує спеціальні  елітні бойові підрозділи,
які повертатимуть Україні її землі.
Це промо-ролик так званої "Гвардії наступу" - проєкту МВС України, за яким до українського війська
набирають вісім нових штурмових бригад добровольців.
Повідомляється, що за перші два тижні ініціативи українці подали понад 15 тисяч заявок,
кілька сотень з них - уже потрапили на навчання.
Охочі самі заповнюють анкету - онлайн, або особисто - у Центрах надання адмінпослуг у своєму місті,
як це сьогодні робить 29-річна Юлія.
Через військкомат коли подаєш, там кажуть "Почекайте, подумайте, а ми вас можемо на блокпост поставити".
Тут швидше відправляють на навчання. Зараз мене несе саме туди, я відчуваю, що я маю бути там.
Жінки активно беруть участь у відборі, каже інспекторка бригади Нацполіції "Лють".
Саме туди хоче потрапити Юлія, втім чи пройде - не знає, попереду кілька етапів конкурсу.
Це ж фізична підготовка, я боксом займалася два роки до цього. Я вважаю, що я готова.
Потім іде тестування, медичне обстеження, перевірка рівня фізичної підготовки, особистісних характеристик,
співбесіда з поліцейською комісією, також спецперевірка.
У кожній області це проходить дуже активно.
Навіть зараз ми відкрили ще додатковий конкурс по Київській області на посаду поліцейських,
які в подальшому будуть направлятися в бригаду "Лють", і це вже буде резерв.
Бо охочих дуже багато.
Загальна мобілізація - на базі територіальних центрів комплектування та соціальної підтримки
- безперервно триває з 24 лютого 2022 року.
Як активно до лав ЗСУ набирають військовозобов’язаних, який відсоток добровольців станом на сьогодні -
на ці запитання протягом кількох тижнів після запиту DW у Київському міському ТЦК
та у командуванні сухопутних військ відповідей не надали.
Пояснюють це міркуваннями безпеки.
Він їде з нами у військкомат! Все! Давай-давай!
Пустіть дитину! Я зараз швидку буду викликати!
Тим часом у соцмережах час від часу ширяться відео, як у різних регіонах українцям,
як стверджують автори контенту, вручають повістки.
Десь доходить до бійки, десь - видно, як невідомі чоловіки у формі тягнуть цивільного у броньований мікроавтобус.
Або не вручають повістки, а одразу заламують руки.
Повістку під розписку маєте дати! Відпустіть його!
Що ви його "ломите"? Він що, зі зброєю, чи що?
Такими кадрами українці обмінюються у спеціальних телеграм-каналах,
де адміністратори повідомляють, як і коли роздають повістки представники військкоматів.
Чи справді це так - для DW прокоментував секретар РНБО Олексій Данілов.
Мовляв, якщо кадри в мережі і правдиві, то це поодинокі випадки, а загальна мобілізація відбувається за планом.
Наші військові, наші сили безпеки і оборони, які безпосередньо приймають участь у цьому процесі,
залучають таку кількість громадян, яку вважають необхідною для виконання тих завдань,
які є на сьогодні. І ніякої трагедії, ніяких форс-мажорів у нас в даному випадку немає.
І вже буде рік, ви не бачили, скажімо так, такого, що були би якісь там речі, які б виходили за межі.
Чи є поодинокі випадки там, де люди несповна розуму роблять ті речі, які точно робити не треба?
Це трапляється, але це поодинокі випадки.
Я хочу звернути увагу, що це не є якась масована така ситуація.
Адвокат Тарас Яресько підтверджує:
Це ініціатива на місцях. Навіть один з місцевих Одеських ТЦК
на своїй сторінці у Фейсбук опублікував певні застереження до громадян:
"Ми так робили і будемо робити". І зараз за участі ОК "Південь" відбуваються оперативно-слідчі дії.
Якщо дивитися з точки зору закону, представники ТЦК не мають права нікого хапати і нікого тягнути.
Під час вручення повістки - чи взяв громадянин цю повістку, чи не взяв - він нічого не порушує.
І хапати його кудись чи тягнути навіть поліція не може, бо не відбувається якогось порушення.
Адвокат Тарас Яресько підтверджує - клієнти дедалі частіше розпитують юристів,
як поводитися у разі вручення повістки на вулиці.
Нерідко звертаються громадяни, яким вручали документ помилково, тобто ті,
хто має відстрочку від призову - люди з інвалідністю, багатодітні батьки, студенти або люди віком 60 плюс.
Причини такого, пояснює правник, у неоновлених даних у ТЦК, про які мають повідомляти самі громадяни.
З одного боку, держава каже: "Не бійтеся мобілізації, приходьте на оновлення даних,
це всього лише оновлення даних".  Є велика проблема в тому,
що в наших ТЦК немає поки що, ще не запущений єдиний реєстр призовників,
військовозобов’язаних і резервістів, який би акумулював ці дані. І виходить, що ТЦК не можуть контролювати,
хто у них на обліку стоїть, більшість справ були на початку війни знищені, деякі через безвідповідальність загублені,
і тому відбувається оця спонтанна істерія з врученням повісток.
Правники наголошують - повістка не означає негайну відправку на фронт.
Такий документ буває двох видів: на уточнення даних для обліку і так звана "бойова" повістка,
після якої військовозобов'язаний за умов допущення до служби відправляється на навчання.
За законом, вручати повістку можуть будь-де, втім лише особисто.
Передача повістки через родичів або інших третіх осіб - є порушенням з боку ТЦК.
Різні бувають випадки. До прикладу, буквально тижні два тому ми бачили, що клеїли повістки
на двері у будинку чи квартирі. Це неналежне оповіщення.
Якщо повістка оформлена і вручена законно, відмова громадянина приймати її
має фіксуватися у спеціальному акті та направлятися до суду.
Якщо йдеться про повістки на уточнення військово-облікових даних, тут застосовується
адміністративна відповідальність, і максимальне покарання, яке може бути, це штраф.
Якщо ми вже говоримо про ухилення від мобілізації, коли вже вручили особі бойову повістку,
і ухиляється особа, тоді ми вже можемо говорити про якусь кримінальну відповідальність.
От буквально недавно читала інформацію, що в Хмельницькому був свіжий вирок
і позбавили особу волі на три роки.
За даними судового реєстру України, у грудні 2022 року справ про ухилянтів
стало вдесятеро менше у порівнянні з березнем - 19 проваджень за місяць.
На думку радника голови Офісу президента України Михайла Подоляка, українці призовного віку
мають нарешті зрозуміти, що мобілізація під час війни критично необхідна для захисту країни
і що просто переказати гроші на ЗСУ - цього недостатньо.
Мобілізація країни під час війни - це готовність країни захищатись.
Це тренування, тренування і ще раз тренування.
Це треба, щоб людина була свідома того, щоб вона не ховалась від розуміння,
що треба навчитись користуватись зброєю, що треба навчитись елементарних речей,
що треба вміти вбивати, бо це психологічно складно.
Оце треба людям пояснювати. І ми недостатньо жорстко це робили. І я вважаю, що це помилка.
Тому що ми вважали, ну, я особисто, що суспільство настільки в нас доросле,
що може само між собою обговорювати всі ці складні речі.
І я ще раз скажу, це не питання патріотизму, донату.
Це питання усвідомлення того, що Росія має програти.
Аби Росія програла швидше, запевняють самі ж військовослужбовці, цивільні чоловіки мають усвідомити -
на фронті необхідна заміна.
Я тільки "за" мобілізацію, чесно! Підмога це завжди класно! Чекаємо!
Це військовослужбовець ЗСУ із позивним "Фанат".
Він керує ротою бійців на одному з напрямків фронту.
Каже, багато його підлеглих не мали відпусток від першого дня повномасштабного вторгнення.
У мене відпустки не було. Я крайній раз був у відпустці, зараз скажу: перед війною за два тижні.
І то, я не догуляв її. Мене викликали на службу, нас всіх викликали.
Ніхто не догуляв свої відпустки. І коли я її догуляю - невідомо нікому взагалі.
Виведення підрозділу із зони бойових дій - це ротація.
При відсутності відпусток за цілий рік повномасштабної війни, у роти "Фаната" була одна єдина ротація
- в січні - тривалістю місяць.
Разом з тим прихід новобранців геть не означає, що досвідчені бійці відпочиватимуть більше.
Адже новачків треба додатково навчати в умовах фронту, каже "Фанат".
Коли приходить дуже багато новоприбулих, їх потрібно навчати, і на це треба час.
Що важливо під час набору людей? Мотивація!
Треба, щоб не тягнули за руки, за вуха у віськкомати, а щоб люди самі йшли.
Треба, щоб всі люди були навчені не гірше тих, хто зараз є у нас.
Нещодавно у соцмережах з'явилася новина про загибель на фронті одного з бійців ЗСУ
- Богдана Покітко з Тернопільщини. За словами журналіста Юрія Бутусова,
чоловіка відправили на фронт недостатньо підготованим.
Днями представник президента у Верховній Раді Федір Веніславський заявив,
що подібні випадки, як і загальні питання процесу мобілізації, влада не лишить без уваги.
У парламенті вже зареєстрували законопроєкт про внесення змін до статті Закону
Про військовий обов’язок і військову службу, а саме - щодо встановлення
мінімального обов’язкового терміну підготовки військових після мобілізації
перед відправкою на фронт.